- What is the point of a
pocket in for like, oh no!
- Today we are getting naked
for the Internet again.
- We're trying on
Valentine's Day lingerie.
- We're back baby!
- I have no experience with
sexy lingerie, which is kinda sad.
- Maybe it'll get us all in the mood.
I'm wearing a dance
belt and we're hiding it
because the dance belt still looks gross.
- How's the butt?
- The butt's great.
- Well, thank you.
- Your butt look good.
- This is a corset, right?
Of course it is.
- I already hate this because there are
way too many clasps on it.
I feel like the sexiest thing clothes
can do is be easy to take off.
- I feel like I'm talkin' a little higher
because it's just sucking everything in.
- The pressure literally
pushed that burp out of me.
- It's like I'm being
punished for dating you.
- How expensive is this nonsense?
- It's like Disney version of sexy.
- I like these!
- I'm looking at this, and I'm confused
because there are so many leg holes.
Oh no, that's not a leg
hole, that's a butt.
- Oh yeah!
- I'm afraid to bend down because
this string may never escape me.
- Oh, this hurts!
The fabric is scratching my stomach.
- They don't show that
part in sexy movies.
Like, you know, you gotta prepare.
- I think this is more
trouble than it's worth.
I think if they had this in velcro, yeah.
- What the (bleep) is this?
- What? Huh?
- This one's really selling
something, you know.
- I am...
Oh, I missed! Ow!
- When I saw this, I'm like,
"How you cover the boobs?"
The answer is, "You don't."
- I need someone's help.
- How can anyone without an
engineering degree figure this out?
- This is a Rubik's Cube of lingerie.
- Who knew being sexy was so hard?
- Does it look like the box?
No!
Does it look like a sexy
train wreck of cables?
Yes!
- If it's even half as hard to
take off as it was to put on,
this is not worth it.
- I don't think men would do
Valentine's Day, if they
had this type of suit.
That's a lot of butt.
- I don't think anyone
would look great in this.
- This does make me feel
differently about Valentine's Day.
It makes me feel like
I'm not missin' much.
- I don't like the name of that.
We should rename this.
- Hello.
- This is what I pictured.
This is what I think lingerie should be.
- I bet Keith likes this.
- What else is there to say, it's cute!
- First of all, easy access.
- It's good because I'm flexible
to go in all different sorts of positions.
- I feel like a bird.
- Like a nice little,
gentle breeze on my legs
that I'm not quite used to.
- This one's cozy.
I feel like a woman could
be sexy, yet comfortable.
- If my wife wore this,
I would be turned on.
- This is the, "I forgot to
get you a present" present.
- This is ripped already.
I assume Ned is to blame.
- Oh, I ripped it!
- This will make so
few people look better.
- I look like the mayor
of a nudist colony.
Like the day you found
out Santa isn't real.
- Does that look like breasts?
- My boob keeps poppin' out.
Get back in there.
- If I straighten up, it
rams the string up my butt.
- I just feel bad that the girls
always have things up their butts.
- Almost like getting it prostate exam.
- It's very obvious to me that
this is not made for all body types.
You better be buyin' me
a nice dinner tonight.
I'm talkin' like all of them.
We're getting dessert too.
If they had man lingerie,
I'm not doin' it.
- I understand it's a lot of work
to put on Valentine's Day lingerie.
Do I still like the way it looks?
I do.
- From tryin' on ladies' underwear before,
I already know it's fairly
uncomfortable and sexy.
This is just extremely
uncomfortable and less sexy.
- If it makes you feel good,
and it makes your partner
think you look extra great,
then I think it's fantastic.
- I mean the point of this is
we just want to have sex, right so...
Let's skip this and just get to it.
- Hold on.
This is the problem with it.
It's so hard to take
it off once I'm ready.
(Coughing)